[Applause]
from intimate stories to Blockbusters
the films nominated for our final award
tonight
brought movie theaters around the world
back to theaters
whether providing a few hours of Welcome
Escape
or the opportunity to connect
emotionally with
different cultures
or inspiring reflection
encouraging empathy
movies can transform Our Lives
the movies we honor tonight
have real power
once again here are the nominees for
Best Picture
All Quiet on the Western Front Avatar
the way of water the Banshees of inner
sharing Elvis
everything everywhere all at once the
Fable ones
top gun Maverick
triangle of sadness
women talking
and the Oscar goes to
everything everywhere
all at once
[Music]
nominated for 11 Academy Awards
everything everywhere all at once won
seven Oscars tonight for actor in a
supporting role actress in a supporting
role original screenplay film editing
directing actress in a leading role and
best picture
laughs
[Applause]
this feels incredible
there is no movie without our brilliant
and big-hearted cast and crew but not
just these beautiful souls here also up
there and in Little Tokyo we see you
so this award is ours
I really it is it's intimidating
speaking up here let me just tell you
that
I never thought I would get to say this
so I say it with one voice with all
these people thank you to the academy
a24
thank you so much you saw our weirdness
and supported us for a year theatrically
that's incredible thank you to my
brilliant and beautiful wife Ani if all
this shiny stuff and tuxedos goes away I
would just love to do laundry and taxes
with you for the rest of my life
but this is for my dad
who like so many immigrant parents died
young and
he is so proud of me not because
of this
but because we made this movie
with what he taught me to do which is no
person is more important than Prophets
and no one is more important than anyone
else and these weirdos right here
supported me in doing that
memory eternal
Daniels I don't know what to say I love
you guys
you just won best picture hey
um we've said enough tonight I just want
to say that thank you so much to
everyone here you have all inspired me I
think one of the things that I realized
growing up was that one of the best
things we can do for each other is
shelter each other from the chaos of
this crazy world we live in thank you to
the storytellers here who did that for
me
um the world is changing rapidly and I
fear that our stories are not keeping at
PACE and I I
um sometimes it's a little scary knowing
that movies move at the the rate of
years and the world on the Internet is
moving at the rate of milliseconds but I
have great faith in our stories story
these stories have changed my life and
they've done that for generations and I
know that we'll get through this
um have a great night guys thank you so
much thank you everyone
thank you